good friend of mine huge marketer he had
done two or three home run infomercials
and he recorded one with Larry King he
flew Larry King out he was going to
interview him about his book I was like
Hey and tonight you're live with Larry
King right and he just did it just like
an episode of Larry King he ran the ad
and it bomed he's like I've done this I
know this is a killer ad like why isn't
this working he went back he watched all
his best infomercials and he realized
that he just missed the hood so he flew
back the entire production crew flew
Larry King back to re-record the first
minute he re-recorded the first minute
with the new script did $100 million the
next year how people perceive the
information matters almost more than the
information itself when you're making
like a short or you're making a tweet or
making an ad like the first 3 seconds is
80 90% of it